we will see time and time again tonight
as we've already seen that my opponent
has a problem with the truth well and
now I have to respond to that we are we
are moving on gentlemen on the face of
it to familiar made for television
debate between contenders for a crucial
senatorial seat in Georgia but there's a
lot at stake here a senate seat
currently held by Democrat Reverend
Draper Warnock but contested by
trump-backed former football star
Republican Herschel Walker
and much like the nearby Savannah River
this turbulence below the surface the
debate comes amid a vicious media attack
campaign showing up at his ex-wife's
house armed with a gun and refusing to
leave
I just can't believe he would have run
me open
anti-abortion candidate Walker is also
accused of funding an abortion for an
ex-girlfriend he denies it but the level
of anger in the campaign reflects the
significance of this particular fight
will it confirm the ship from the right
signaled in the Democrats Victory two
years ago is the state of Georgia going
to continue that Trend towards
Democratic or is it going to go back to
Republican a lot of that will have to do
with the motivation of the voters in
Georgia going into this midterm election
we know that it's also important on a
national level and this election will
also be a measure of the lingering
influence of Donald Trump so Herschel
please say a few words who has
wholeheartedly endorsed Herschel Walker
I only need 11 000 votes fellas I need
11 000 votes give me a break the former
president is facing potential legal
issues in Georgia because of his
attempts to change the official election
count in 2020. president Trump is my
friend and he won't stand up with Biden
when yet he's voted with him 96 percent
of the time I think that part of the
problem with our politics right now
is that it's become too much about the
politicians the Vice President in the
past television debates had a direct
impact on election results but as Trump
himself has demonstrated in 2022 it
doesn't appear to matter what the
candidate says or does as long as the
party wins the debate has put on display
the degree of animosity that has
permeated these midterm elections in a
bitterly divided United States
what was once a ripple on the body
politic is now a churning tide
Mike Hannah Al Jazeera Savannah